today uh
as we watch freedom and liberty under
attack abroad
i'm here to fulfill my responsibilities
under the constitution
to preserve freedom and liberty here in
the united states of america
and it's my honor to introduce to the
country
a daughter of former public school
teachers
a proven consensus builder
an accomplished lawyer
a distinguished jurist
one of the nation's most on one of the
nation's most prestigious courts
my nominee for the united states supreme
court is judge catan g jackson
you know uh four weeks ago when
a member of the court
friend of mine who used to work together
in the senate
justice stephen breyer announced his
retirement
i said then choosing someone to serve on
the united states supreme court is one
of the most serious
constitutional responsibility a
president has and i mean it
i promised the process would be rigorous
that i would select a nominee worthy of
justice briar's legacy of excellence and
decency
someone extremely qualified with a
brilliant legal mind with the utmost
character and integrity which equally is
important
and though i would bring
this decision
to this decision my perspective as a
lawyer
former constitutional law professor
chairman of the justice committee for
many many years
and i'm almost reluctant to say it
someone who's been presided over more
supreme court nominations than almost
anyone
living today which makes me 28 years old
i started doing it when i was 32.
and uh who was devoted much of my career
to thinking about the constitution and
the role of the supreme court
with that perspective
i carefully stuttered the right study
the record of candidates
i've invited senators of both political
parties to offer their ideas and points
of view and i've met with a number of
them
as a result
i because i i truly respect not only the
consent i know they give consent but it
said that the constitution says advice
and consent
and i sought the advice of democrats and
republicans
i've consulted with leading
legal scholars and lawyers
and i've been fortunate to have the
advice of the vice president harris i
mean this sincerely an exceptional
lawyer a former attorney general in
california
and a former member of the senate
judiciary committee
and during this process you look for
someone who like justice breyer has a
pragmatic understanding that the law
must work for the american people
someone who has historical perspective
to understand that the constitution
is a resilient charter of liberty
someone with the wisdom to appreciate
that the constitution protects certain
inalienable rights
rights that fall within the most
fundamental personal freedoms
that our society recognizes
in the end someone with extraordinary
character
will bring to the supreme court an
independent mind uncompromising
integrity and with a strong moral
compass and the courage to stand up for
what she thinks is right
for too long
our government our courts
haven't looked like america and i
believe it's time that we have a court
reflects the full talents and greatness
of our nation
with a nominee of extraordinary
qualifications
and that we inspire all young people to
believe that they can one day
serve their country at the highest level
i've admired these traits of pragmatism
historical perspective wisdom character
in the jurors nominated by republican
presidents as well as democratic
presidents
and today
i'm pleased to introduce to the american
people a candidate who continues in this
great tradition
judge jackson grew up in miami florida
and by the way the mayor of miami
republican endorsed you i thought that
was interesting
her parents grew up with segregation but
never gave up hope
that their children would enjoy the true
promise of america
her parents graduated from historic
black colleges and became public school
teachers her mom a principal her dad a
teacher who later went back to school
and became a lawyer representing that
very school district that school board
judge jackson describes finding her love
for the law from an apartment complex at
the university of miami where her dad
was attending law school
she'd draw in her coloring book at the
dining room table next to her dad's law
books
she grew up to be a star student
elected mayor of her junior high school
and president of her high school class
where she was a standout she was a
standout on the speech and debate team
and it was after a debate tournament
that took place at harvard when she was
in high school that she believed she
could one day be a student there
there were those who told her she
shouldn't set her sights too high
but she refused to accept limits
others set for her
she had gone to harvard under school
where she graduated magnum [ __ ] laude
she went into to attend harvard law
school where she was a top student and
editor of the prestigious law review
then
she applied for a highly competitive and
coveted clerkship on the united states
supreme court and she was selected
the justice who thought she was worthy
of this high honor was a young lawyer
was none other than justice stephen
breyer
whose seat i'm nominating her to phil
not only did she learn
about being a judge from justice breyer
himself
she saw the great rigor through which
justice breyer approached his work
she learned from his willingness to work
with colleagues with different
viewpoints
critical qualities for my view for any
supreme court justice
now years later
she steps up to fill justice breyer's
place in the court with a uniquely
accomplished and wide-ranging background
she served both in public service
as a federal public defender a federal
public defender and in private law
practice
as an accomplished lawyer
with a prestigious law firm
if confirmed
she will join justice sotomayor
as the only other member of the united
states supreme court who has experience
as a trial court judge
a critical qualification in my view
and once again
following the footsteps of her mentor
justice breyer she'd become the only
member of the court who previously
served as a member of the united states
sentencing commission
and she brings additional perspective to
the court as well
she comes from a family of law
enforcement
with her brother and uncles having
served as police officers
that's one reason i expect by the
fraternal order police the national
organization today said and i quote
there's little doubt she's has the
temperament the intellect and legal
experience and family background have
earned disappointment
and they went on to say
they're confident she will quote
approach her future cases with an open
mind and treat issues related to law
enforcement fairly and justly
incredibly
judge jackson has already been confirmed
by the united states senate three times
first to serve on the u.s sentencing
commission
a bipartisan independent commission we
helped design to reduce the unwarranted
disparities in sentencing
and promote transparency and fairness in
the criminal justice system
on the commission
judge jackson was known for working with
democrats and republicans to find common
ground on critical issues
second
she was concerned but confirmed by the
united states senate with bipartisan
support
on the federal district court to
administer justice the special rigors
and fairness that come presiding over
trials
and third
she was confirmed with bipartisan senate
vote to serve on the u.s court of
appeals for the district of columbia
considered the second most powerful
court behind the supreme court itself
and the court she once argued cases
before as a distinguished advocate
and when judge jackson was nominated to
the circuit court
one of his distinguished retired members
judge thomas griffin
a former general counsel of brigham
young university
and a george bush appointee to the court
said he backed her enthusiastically
hailing her hailing her exemplary legal
career in both public and private
practice
and went on to say
her careful approach as a trial court
judge
judge jackson's service on the district
circuit court of the d.c circuit court
of appeals is another superb
qualification for service on the supreme
court
three of her of the current supreme
court justices also served as the tc
circuit judges when john jackson's now
serves
her opinions are always carefully
reasoned tethered to precedent and
demonstrate reflect respect for how the
law impacts everyday people
it doesn't mean she puts her thumb on
the scale of justice one way or the
other
but she understands the broader impact
of her decisions
whether it's cases addressing the rights
of workers or government service
she cares about making sure that a
democracy works for the american people
she listens
she looks people in the eye lawyers
defendants victims and families
and she strives to ensure that everyone
understands why she made a decision
what the law is and what it means to
them
she strives to be fair
to get it right
to do justice
that's something all of us should
remember
and it's something i've thought about
throughout this process
as a matter of fact i thought about it
walking over here with her
one floor below
we have several displays celebrating
black history month
one of them
includes the judicial oath of office
taken and signed by
justice thurgood marshall himself
an oath
that will be once again administered to
a distinguished american
who will help write the next chapter in
the history of the journey of america
a journey that judge jackson will take
with her family
i hope i don't embarrass him but her
husband patrick i'm a surgeon doctor
patrick stand up let him see who you are
there you go
they met when they were undergraduate
students at harvard and he's this
distinguished cancer surgeon at
georgetown
and like so many women in this country
judge jackson is a working mom
she had her eldest child
natalia when she was a private lawyer in
practice she had her second child laila
when she served as u.s on the u.s
sentencing commission stand up leo
i asked layla when i showed her through
the office whether she'd like to be
president she looked
there's other things
anyway layla you're welcome to be here
thank you so much
and welcome
your sister who's up in school in rhode
island now
i have children and grandchildren let me
tell you judge
you're always a mom
that's not going to change no matter
what you're doing
you're on whether you're on the supreme
court or not
and i've always had a deep respect for
the supreme court and judiciary as a
co-equal branch of the government i mean
it
the court is equally as important as the
presidency or the congress it's co-equal
so today
i'm pleased to nominate judge jackson
will bring extraordinary qualifications
deep experience and intellect and a
rigorous judicial record to the court
judge jackson deserves to be confirmed
as the next justice of the supreme court
i've met with the chairman and ranking
members of the senate judiciary
committee
senator dick durbin senator chuck
grassley and my hope is that they will
move promptly and i know they'll move
fairly
judge jackson congratulations
and the podium is yours let me pull this
out for you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else